[Música]
en este segmento el invitado del día lo
vamos a dedicar a analizar los sucesos
son más importantes de este 2022 hacemos
un repaso general de todos estos
acontecimientos antes de nuestro receso
por la festividades de diciembre y
hablamos hoy de la guerra en Ucrania que
se acerca a los 10 meses desde su inicio
el pasado 24 de febrero hacemos un
balance de lo que ha ocurrido y hasta
donde se puede dirigir este conflicto
nos acompaña nuestro estudio Margarita
cadavid de jazz internacionalista de la
Universidad del Rosario en Colombia
experta en temas de derechos humanos y
también resolución de conflictos son
Margarita Gracias por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de lunes en directo América
de France 24 muchas gracias a ustedes
por la invitación y a la audiencia
Margarita hagamos primero que todo
digamos un balance de lo que ha sido en
general a toda esta guerra en Ucrania
desde el inicio de la invasión rusa el
pasado 24 de febrero Cómo se fueron
dando las cosas
bueno Pues básicamente como todos
sabemos Ucrania vivía un momento en su
historia en el que estaba metida Entre
dos mundos no era o la Unión Europea o
Rusia y después de lo que todos vivimos
de las protestas del euromaidan y lo que
pasó precisamente con la invasión en el
2014 a crimea y el famoso referéndum que
se hizo de manera arbitraria violando el
derecho internacional estábamos
pendientes de que iba a pasar con la
región del Don vas y el conflicto en el
don vas y finalmente termina esto en una
intervención militar que Putin llamó una
operación militar rápida y evidentemente
esa operación militar especial que iba a
ser muy rápida no lo fue fue una
operación militar que nos llevó a una
guerra que todavía estamos digamos
viviendo y que ha traído yo diría muchos
analistas afirman de los errores de
Putin en esta guerra no porque creo que
hubo varias cosas que no se previeron o
que hubo un mal cálculo quizás político
se inició violando por supuesto el
derecho internacional porque esto es sin
lugar a dudas una agresión Aquí no hay
un casos bellum que la justifique por
bajo ninguna circunstancia entonces una
de las primeras cosas que hay que decir
es Putin se equivoca pensando o
subestimando la respuesta ucraniana y la
resistencia además de un ejército de
voluntarios son cien mil voluntarios que
están siendo además armados y yo diría
que ese va a ser uno de los problemas a
futuro no porque cuando tú armas
población civil para responder a
situaciones militares como esta pues la
guerra se vuelve una guerra prolongada
uno y dos como haces para el desarme
Entonces yo diría que un primer una un
primer análisis que podemos hacer
nosotros es la duración esto se ha
desbordado de la de los digamos
territorios que había logrado ocupar
Putin que había logrado entrar Ya son
más de seis mil kilómetros cuadrados que
él ha tenido que retroceder Y eso genera
digamos una sensación de desconfianza y
de Hacia dónde va en el en Rusia todavía
tiene el apoyo de las élites en cuanto a
la población es difícil saberlo es
difícil saberlo digamos por la
restricción en los medios de
comunicación pero sin embargo vemos que
las fronteras estuvieron desbordadas en
algún momento de rusos cuando se llamó a
la movilización general los rusos
yéndose para Turquía para
otras zonas entonces ahí ya hay un apoyo
que empieza a flaquear no el segundo
punto tendríamos que decir que tiene que
ver con la otan todo esto se genera por
la expansión de la otan hacia Europa del
es una expansión que había empezado
desde hace mucho tiempo una Rusia que
quiere mantener sus zonas de influencia
en el área eposoviética y que contrario
a lo que se pensaba esto lo he ido
alejando de esas áreas de influencia y
no solamente alejado a Rusia de sus
áreas de influencia
que lo otro que ha causado es una
ampliación de la otan fíjate que tenemos
dos nuevos ingresos a la otan dos nuevos
miembros en latam y
miembros cercanos también a Rusia
digamos en términos de vecindad y el
otro tema es que tan que tan fuerte fue
ese apoyo que Rusia esperó tener de
China no y el apoyo de China ha sido un
apoyo como es china bastante hermético
es yo no intervengo en los asuntos
internos de otros países yo en esto no
me meto y es yo diría un poco del jabón
ponzio no me lavo las manos y no no
entro aquí pero en términos económicos
ese apoyo digamos ha sido más firme en
términos económicos por lo que vemos que
se está viviendo hoy con el tope del
precio del petróleo que dicen Bueno aquí
le vamos los que le compren petróleo a
Rusia a 60 dólares hoy inician además
todas las el embargo Pues los sanciones
sin embargo que se había impuesto y
China dice yo siempre he tenido una
relación comercial con Rusia y lo que
nos convenga a los dos pero entonces yo
diría que esas tres cosas una
prolongación de la guerra en el tiempo
que va a empezar a ser flaquear los
apoyos de Putin internamente en términos
de Internacionales vemos Que Putin está
aislado internacionalmente Putin se fue
quedando sin amigos y creo que ese
primer momento donde se pensó que
algunos digamos más
prorusos decían Este es el momento en el
que Rusia se va a fortalecer pensaron
que esto iba a ser como 2008 Georgia
del sur pensaron que iba a ser como 2014
crimea y resulta que se calculó falló el
segundo punto entonces Además del
aislamiento de Putin es una imagen
desgastada internacionalmente y Bueno
aquí hay un tercer factor que hay que
tener en cuenta y es el tema de los
alimentos el tema de la ciudad de
precios sobre todos los granos si esto
es algo que puede afectar el medio
oriente mucho los principales
importadores de granos ucranianos están
ahí medio oriente y África Sudán a
Egipto 69% entonces Turquía ha sido
digamos un
contribuido a que ese grano pase por ahí
ya disminuido los efectos pero no de la
manera que se esperaba Entonces yo creo
que esto es como el balance general y me
atrevería a decir con creo que la
invasión a Ucrania fue un error y está
desgastando la posición de Rusia
internacionalmente y la imagen de Putin
internacionalmente lo ha dejado aislado
Margarita bueno completo digamos
análisis de estos casi 10 meses de
guerra lo pues trataste de resumir de la
mejor manera posible Yo también quería
que conversáramos sobre la amenaza
nuclear no que va y viene en este
momento Pues se ve alejada no se volvió
pero en un momento Si estuvo muy
caliente como vemos esto en esta guerra
también en qué quedará todo este tema de
la energía y hacia dónde vamos Bueno
pues con respecto a la amenaza nuclear
esto tiene que ver precisamente con la
prolongación de la guerra Putin tuvo que
empezar a a crear nuevas estrategias
estrategias mucho más agresivas y se
unen se unan las dos cosas por ejemplo
lo que tú estabas diciendo con respecto
a el tema energético una de las cosas
que vemos que está pasando hoy en
Ucrania es que los bombardeos que está
haciendo Putin son las centrales
energéticas Nosotros sabemos que
históricamente en todos los momentos
Rusia y la unión soviética y hoy otra
vez Rusia utilizan el invierno como una
estrategia de guerra entonces golpear es
golpear la infraestructura energética es
una de las herramientas para presionar a
la población a una rendición y creo que
esto tiene un efecto contrario Esto está
teniendo un efecto contrario y está
teniendo un efecto contrario no
solamente internamente sino de
solidaridad internacional con la
población ucraniana y el segundo punto
es la amenaza nuclear Putin empieza con
su amenaza nuclear también elevando
digamos esas tratar de salir lo más
rápido posible a esta guerra pero la
respuesta de Estados Unidos Fue
contundente Porque además Esto va aunado
un cambio de estrategia donde el cambio
de estrategia fue vamos a anexionarnos
las regiones entonces
anexiona esas cuatro regiones obviamente
esas anexiones no tienen reconocimiento
internacional ni ningún peso pero
inmediatamente dice y vamos a utilizar
la la guerra nuclear pues amenaza No
claro para minimizar esta expresión Y
entonces inmediatamente Estados Unidos
dice lo que pase y el uso de armamento
nuclear será respondido por los Estados
Unidos entonces ahí ya también dejó
Estados Unidos una carta sobre la mesa y
no creo que ninguno ninguno en este
momento esté dispuesto a eso yo creo que
se está utilizando como un elemento de
situación y quedamos como en la Guerra
Fría no la disuasión por la destrucción
mutua asegurada con armamento nuclear
por eso Putin le bajó al discurso de El
armamento nuclear en este momento
Margarita Muchísimas gracias por el
tiempo evidentemente se nos quedan a
muchas cosas por fuera pero Tratamos de
en este segmento Pues de tocar los
puntos más importantes de lo que ha sido
estos casi 10 meses de guerra y ha sido
donde podría ir que al final pues no
vamos a especular sino que vamos a
esperar que nos dice el tiempo Margarita
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes Muchas
gracias